good morning and good afternoon everyone
welcome to today's webinar entitled the
growing concern of off target effects
how to monitor and minimize off targets
in your your genome editing experiment
my name is louise baskin i'm going to be
the moderator for today's event
this educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits so
just click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits
and we do encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation
to do this you just type them into the
ask a question box and click send
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
and you can also submit any technical
issues using this method as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
but with that i'm going to turn it over
to our speaker pandy de pachenard she is
a product manager for genome editing at
thermo fisher scientific so pandita i'll
turn over to you to begin your
presentation
hi everyone my name is pandita
postnaught and i'm the product manager
for genome editing at thermo fissure
scientific for today's presentation i'll
be talking in detail about the growing
concerns of off-target effects in
general editing experiments
i will discuss available methods and
strategies that can be taken to monitor
and minimize off-target effects for your
application
just wanted to go over quickly the
agenda for today we'll start off with
talking a little bit about the crispr
cas9 system
then go into a little bit more detail
about what off-target events are and why
you should be concerned
and follow closely with strategies to
reduce off-target events
and finally talking about the
in vitrogen true cut hifi-cas9 protein
and then close off the discussion with a
summary and q a
genome editing has become exceedingly
popular in common places due to the
crispr cas9 revolution
crisprcas9 has been a significant
paradigm shift in functional genomics
research and has made genome editing
easier and more accessible to a wide
array of researchers like never before
i would like to start off with a quick
overview of the crispr cas9 system
crispr cas9 is an rna-guided nuclease
system that was first identified as an
adaptive bacterial immune response
pathway the specificity of the system is
due to the rna-guided nature of the
system
it comprises of two main components the
guide rna which contains the sequence
that guides the protein to the target
location
it is a duplex of crispr rna and tracer
rna molecules
and in the second equally as important
component of this crispr cas9 system is
our cas9 nuclease
it's a protein that performs the actual
cutting or cleavage
once guided to the intended location by
the guide rna
the crispr casting system is dependent
on what we call a proto-spacer adjacent
motive or pam site for the guide rna to
recognize the target site on the genome
the crispr cas9 system can be delivered
into the cells in three different
formats plasmid
rna or protein
many researchers actually favored the
delivery of the protein rna complex or
rnp
which we'll talk in a lot more detail
later in this presentation
the first i want to introduce one of the
highly successful genome editing
products developed by thermal fischer
the in vitrogen truecad cas9 protein v2
it is the wild-type cas9 protein that's
been engineered to give it a very high
specificity into the nucleus of the
eukaryotic cells
this allows it to consistently deliver
high editing efficiency in all tested
cell types
we also have several validated protocols
in neural cell numerous cell types
available to help researchers get the
highest efficiency and success with our
protein
and as you see here on the slide
some of the data in the cancer cell line
on the right hand side
we also demonstrated high editing
efficiency when using truecut cas9
protein v2 in more therapeutically
relevant cell types such as primary t
cells
here on the slide you see on target
editing efficiency approaching a hundred
percent
for more information on the data as well
as the protocol please visit
thermofisher.com where an application
note is available on this particular
experiment
with crispr cas9 holding so much promise
and with increased adoption
there are emerging concerns about
off-target events
in crispr cas9 mediated genome editing
now off-target events occur when
unintended edits happen
so this could potentially add another
variables or unknowns to your experiment
this is particularly important to
monitor and minimize off-target effects
especially for therapeutics application
to make sure that any risk associated
with these undesired edits are
controlled or reduced for your
experiment
as you can imagine with off target
events you don't
know where the edits may have occurred
as such depending on where the edits
happen in the genome it could
potentially
affect the phenotypes of your cell
models
as i mentioned previously off-target
effects can
affect your genome editing experiment
one of the main reasons that researchers
are concerned about off target is when
they are working towards products such
for cell and gene therapy
in something as high value and well
regulated as these applications it is
important to use a system that will
minimize the risk of undesired genomic
changes
as a result it is particularly important
for therapeutics application that you
are able to firstly screen or monitor
for off-target effects
and in combination with that implement
strategies to minimize off-target
effects in your experiment altogether
some of the key strategies that we'll be
discussing in more detail today
include the use of rnp delivery format
high scoring guide rnas
or high fidelity cas9 to help
reduce the overall
occurrence of off target effects in your
experiment
so as i've alluded to previously it is
important to be aware of strategies that
are available for you to implement to
help reduce off target effects in your
experiment
so first off on the left hand side here
rnp delivery format i'm not going to go
into a lot of detail on this first
strategy today except to say that rnp
or protein guide rna complex is a
favorite format for its ability to
provide an initial high level of crispr
cas9 when introduced into the cells
followed by a rapid decay
and the
reason for this is the higher or more
sustained level of this crispr cas9 tool
in cells typically lead to more
off-target effects so with the
introduction of this tool as an rnp
format and its ability to quickly clear
the cells
leading to a reduced occurrence of of
target effects
second strategy here is in using high
scoring guide rna and we'll spend a
little bit more time on the next two
strategies today
so firstly with the use of high scoring
guide rna
you can leverage an in silicon design
tool such as our in vitrogen true design
genome editor to predict potential of
target sites for the intended edit
you're looking to achieve
from this tool you'll be provided with a
ranked list of guide rna based on score
and the score takes into account
different parameters such as predicted
efficiency specificity and proximity to
the edit site
now one thing to note as it relates to
high scoring guide rna is there are
certain limitations that may prevent
users from
having
a good variety a good choice of guide
rnas this includes perhaps there may not
be any or no pam sites available near
your intended target
as well
with the guide rna
selection that is provided by the tool
the efficiency and or the off target
profile may not be
optimal
and then the third strategy here is the
use of high fidelity cas9 this is a cas9
enzyme that's been engineered to
demonstrate high specificity what that
means is it exhibits
off target profile by reducing off
target events but then one of the
trade-offs that we would have to keep in
mind as it relates to all high fidelity
cast 9 is you would see some reduction
in on target editing efficiency when
compared to our wild type task 9 protein
so just some of the things to keep in
mind as we go through this presentation
to talk in a little bit more detail on
the strategies to reduce off target
events
so now let's dive into a little bit more
detail on the role of guide rnas and of
target effects
one thing i wanted to start off with is
to say that the precision of the crispr
cas9 system is driven by its ability to
find the perfect match between the guide
rna and the target dna
so when this happens or when there is a
perfect match you get what's called a
perfect duplex or an on target guide rna
design shown here on the left hand side
as you can see there's no mismatches
anywhere and you just are able to
achieve that perfect duplex between the
guide
and the target dna
however the system itself can actually
tolerate some base pair mismatches which
can potentially lead to off-target
effects or sites shown here on the right
hand side
off-target effects occur when there are
base pair mismatches between the guide
rna and the target dna which means that
the protein or the cast 9 didn't
necessarily cut at precisely where we
want it to cut
so again when these off-target events
happen it could lead to unintended
changes or edit within your cell model
which could
affect the phenotype
of your model right so depending on
where the off-target events occur
it could lead to unexpected changes
because you don't know if those
off-target events hit a vital coding
gene is that going to kill my cells you
know other edits or the phenotypes that
i'm seeing is it because of my intended
target or is it because of these
off-target effects
so again going to the point of
off target effects just introduce
another variable or unknowns into your
model
to facilitate guide rna design we do
offer the free online true design genome
editor software which is available here
you can visit
our software at thermofisher.com true
design the tool itself provides a fast
and easy design of crispr guide rna for
your genome editing projects
so for all of the guide rna designs the
tool will carry out an analysis of
predicted off-target cut sites so that
you can fully assess the predicted
potential of each guide rna specificity
additionally the tool also offers a
one-stop shop environment where you can
easily order other genome editing
reagents including cast 9 primers and or
transfection reagents in one convenient
location
if you want to learn more about our true
design genome editor we have several
tutorial videos workflow guides as well
as a webinar available online so that
you can you know check it out if you
would like to
learn more about our software
now going back to the strategy that
second strategy around the use of high
scoring guide rna to minimize off target
effects let's dive into a little bit
more detail here so what i'm showing is
a screenshot
from the in vitrogen true design
software
it's showing the location of a desired
knock-in of a fluorescent reporter
you can see here in the snippet up top
and then when the software scan the
nearby region you can see that in the
result table here that i'm showing that
there are plenty of locus where there's
a lot of adjacent pam sites to choose
from you can see the column that says
pam site right
um and the algorithm score
i'm showing here five different guide
rnas and you can see that the algorithm
scored the guides very highly
all of them above 98
and each of them have no more than two
predicted off target sites as shown here
in the table
one thing to note as i mentioned by
leveraging the software you're able to
quickly design or identify the guide rna
that's
appropriate for your intended edit
and through this table you have the
option to pick um the highest scoring
guide rna for your intended edit
one thing to note is for the predicted
off target sites as i mentioned that
each of them have at least you know at
most two off-target sites
but for the predicted off target for
each guide rna you can also click on the
link to get more information as i'm
showing here in my third image more
information on the predicted off target
including location as well as
as identity of the base pair mismatches
but overall you can see that for this
particular target location there are
actually plenty of high scoring guide
rnas to choose from that has minimal
off-target events so in this situation
for this particular edit you have a lot
of options from a guide rna design
perspective
to help minimize off target events
so why not just always choose very
specific guide rna or very high scoring
guide rna for all of your genome editing
experiments
so the problem here is that researchers
may sometimes be forced to use guide rna
designs with higher than desired off
target events
so in this example here i'm showing you
know we're trying we're attempting an
edit at a different locus this time
we're attempting to do a snip shown here
in blue and as you can see
for this particular edit that i'm trying
to do i only get one predicted guide rna
and is only predicted to have a very
moderate performance
of about 74
with 35 potential off target sites
so as a result
since i only have one guide rna to pick
from this limitation
again
is
like i don't have a lot of option or
choice to work with right um and one
thing to note is generally around the
limitation of guide rna choices it's
mostly driven by
you know what the edit that you're
trying to achieve as well as the
surrounding sequence space
there may be very few or no pam sites
available adjacent to the desired edit
site
and in this situation you may have to
work
with
what you have from a guide rna
perspective again you only have one
guide rna and the scoring is not great
it's not very high right at 74
and as you can see with the number of
off target sites that are predicted of
35 this may not necessarily be the most
specific guide rna for you to work with
so in that situation what are you going
to do since you are now limited from a
guide rna aspect
and the key takeaway here is not all
edit sites have high scoring and
specific guide rna to choose from right
as we've mentioned
choosing or using high scoring guide rna
is one of the strategy to help minimize
off target effects
so then i want to segue into our third
strategy which is around high fidelity
cast 9. so i first wanted to start off
by talking about you know what is a high
fidelity cast 9
a high fidelity cas9 is a cas9 variant
that contains additional point mutations
so it's been engineered with that
additional point mutation to demonstrate
improved specificity
or equivalent to improve off-target
profile
so how does it work so with this point
mutation that's been introduced into the
cas9 enzyme what it did is it
destabilized the interaction between the
cas9 protein and the target dna
so when this occurs
that's why for the hifi cas9 protein
it's less likely because of that
disruption in the interaction between
the cas9 protein and the target dna what
it does is the protein itself is less
likely to bind to any off-target
sequence
due to the point mutation
so what this results in is you know
improve specificity
or you know
improve off-target profile but then on
the flip side you also lose a little bit
on an on target editing efficiency front
also on the slide you'll find a table um
comparing the performance of a wild type
cast 9 to a high fidelity cast 9.
so with our wild type cast 9 we know as
i've shown you previously with our true
cut cast 9 protein v2 that it
demonstrates excellent or really high on
target editing efficiency
but what it doesn't do so well off is
that ability to demonstrate or reduce
off target events
then on the flip side with the high
fidelity cast 9 and the engineering that
went into
destabilizing that interaction
what you gain with the high fidelity
cast 9 is in its ability to greatly or
significantly reduce off target effect
and then as i mentioned you lose a
little bit on the on target editing
efficiency when compared to the wild
type cast 9.
so that's fundamentally the trade-off or
the difference between wild type cast
nine and a high fidelity cast nine right
so with that in mind we set out to
identify the best high fidelity cas9
protein candidate that would offer the
superior off-target profile while still
maintaining or preserving the high on
target editing efficiency as much as
possible
so we've taken the following approach
captured here on the slide in our quest
to identify the best hificast 9
candidate
so first what we did was we screened
several hificat9 candidates both from an
in-house candidates as well as those in
published literature
we screened it for off target for its
off-target profile using next generation
sequencing
we then validate those off target
results using ion ampliseq technology
and then lastly because we're trying to
find that
that right balance between off target
and retaining on target editing
efficiency we also evaluated the high
fidelity cast 9 candidates for its on
target editing efficiency as well
so again we're really looking to find
the best candidate
that would offer the superior off target
profile that we expect from high
fidelity cast 9 while still maintaining
the high on target editing efficiency
so now let's talk a little bit more
about the analysis tool that we use to
screen for off target events
so there are several
detection tools available including the
in cellular detection tool such as guide
seek that is very commonly used for
off-target detection
and the idea within cellular method is
it more closely represents the cellular
nucleus based gene editing environment
as opposed to other in vitro detection
methods
however we know that for most of the
available incellular tools there are
some issues related to the sensitivity
especially with its ability to detect
low frequency of target effects
and this is primarily due to the
non-specific amplifi amplification step
of guide seek
so to address this sensitivity issue we
leverage techseq which is an adaption
of guide seek that would offer a more
targeted genome editing of target
screening method
and i'll go into that in more detail in
my next slide
here is a quick overview of techseq
which once again is an adaption of guide
seat
it includes the introduction of a short
double stranded tag that is delivered
into the cells along with the crispr
cas9 tool
this ds tag is integrated into the
genome where the cleavage occurred
then through the use of a phosphorylated
primers we are able to achieve more
specific amplification
resulting in an output that looks very
similar to the table shown here on the
right hand side
for more information on techseq i've
included here on the slide some
publication that go into more detail
about the method and procedure
i also want to note that through our
custom biology services team techseek is
also offered as a custom service
so now that we've learned a little bit
more about techseq let's go into the
first step that we took to identify the
best high fidelity cast 9 candidate
so here we've screened seven different
high fidelity cast 9 candidates
and benchmarked that against the
wildtype cast 9 protein using techseq
on the left hand side you'll find the
output from techseq where the green row
on the top represents the on target
location and every other rose beneath it
represents off target locations
so you'll find that as you look from
left to right in the table going from
wild type all the way through the
different variants of the high fidelity
cas9 you see more zeros which represents
less off target sites that were
registered with taxi
then on on the right hand side in the
bar graph here's a summary of the
results so as i mentioned while typecast
9 we identify 34 off target locations
and as we go through the different high
fidelity cast 9 variants you see that
drop in the number of off target sites
with high fidelity cast 9 variant 4
the orange bar on the most right
of the graph you see that with high
fidelity variant 4 it eliminated 75
percent of the off target events that
were detected when compared to wild type
cast 9.
so again just by going to
the high fidelity cast 9 we saw the best
result with the hi-fi variant 4 being
able to eliminate 75 of off target
events when compared to wild type cast
9.
then what we did was taking that
tech seek result we're now
validating it using ion amplicy
technology
so on the left hand side you'll see a
heat heat map again the target here is
the heck 4 loci we did a similar
comparison where the wild type cast nine
is on the left most column and then
gradually go through the different hi-fi
cast nine variants
so you'll see that the number in each of
in the in the table represents
off-target editing percentage
so once again with variant 4 we saw that
it has the lowest percentage of off
target edits
and then once we do
an expanded
we screen across an expanded panel this
time looking across 24 different loci
we identified high fidelity variant four
on the right hand side the orange bar as
being the most specific
again this data right here is normalized
against the wild type cast 9 so you see
that with the high fidelity cast 9
variant 4 it only registered 39 percent
off target edits when compared to the
wild type cast 9.
and then finally
once we saw that great off target
profile as i mentioned we want to check
to make sure that with this high
fidelity cas9 variant 4 which has the
best off target profile that it's able
to maintain also a high on target
editing efficiency
so what you see on this table in this
slide right here the bar graph on the
left hand side is once again the average
percentage on target editing normalized
to wow type cast nine
so you'll see the wild type cast nine
having a hundred percent and we saw that
with the other high fidelity variant one
and two it also was able to preserve a
pretty high percentage of on target
editing
with the high fidelity variant 4
exhibiting over 86 percent on target
editing efficiency right so it's able to
preserve
over 86 percent of what we would see
with the wild type cast 9.
so that superior that performance on the
on target editing efficiency front
together with the superior off target
profile and results that we saw in the
previous slides we then proceeded to
select the high fidelity cast 9 variant
4
as our new
product the in vitrogen truecut hificat9
protein
so in introducing our true cut hifi cas9
protein it's a cast 9 variant that's
been engineered to demonstrate a
superior off target profile while
maintaining high on target editing
efficiency
our data showed near complete
elimination of off-target events at key
loci in a number of cell types including
primary immune and stem cells
we saw better off target profile with
the true cut hi-fi cas9 protein when
compared to the wild-type truecut cas9
protein v2
what we also saw was a better off-target
profile relative to other suppliers hifi
cast nine
and then lastly we were able to maintain
that maximum on target cleavage due to
the unique cast 9 modifications in
engineering that we did to our
truecadcast 9
products
so
so over the next few slides we're going
to be going over some of the data
using the true cut hi-fi cas9 protein in
therapeutically relevant cell types so
we perform we
perform an experiment in human primary t
cells as well as human induced
pluripotent stem cells
so what i'm showing first here is the
data
in primary t cells so in using the true
cut hifi cas9 protein we saw fewer off
target events when compared to the wild
type cast 9 as well as a different
supplier hifi cas9
so what we did for this experiment is we
we used 21 guide rna
targeting four
party related therapeutic genes
including trac cd52 track b pd1
and then as i mentioned we edited the
cells using the trucad cas9 protein v2
or our wild type another supplier is
high fidelity cast 9 and finally
benchmark that against our true cut
hificast 9 protein
so the dots on the slide
the red dots represent on target events
so you see that in this graphic right
here the data is represented as
the read per million or rpm at the off
target location
over the on target location rpm so it's
displayed as a ratio
the red dot represents on target events
and each of the gray dots
represents an observe of target event
so you see
that
each of the enzyme
the result is divided into four
different quadrants each of the quadrant
represents the therapeutic genes that
we've selected
so in the red box here you'll find the
results of the true cut hificast
you see
if we look at pd1 which just happens to
have the most gray dots across the
different nucleuses that we tested so
with the true cut hificast nine you see
significantly less gray dots which once
again represent off target event when
compared to the supplier high fidelity
cast 9 as well as the wild type true cut
cas9 protein v2
and in general if you look at the other
three genes that we targeted you also
see significantly less of target events
when using our true cut high five cas9
compared to
the other two enzymes that we benchmark
against
right so this further confirmed that by
using our truecut hi-fi cas9 protein we
were able to significantly reduce
off-target events across all target loci
in primary t cells
then we look again still in t cells now
we look at the on target editing
efficiency in the bar graph shown on the
slide you see the average normalized
percent of on target editing efficiency
we have split it between indels and hdr
but you'll see that with this data
that's been normalized to the wild type
cast 9
we see that with the true cut hifi cas9
protein we saw a higher editing
efficiency when
compared to
the other supplier hificast 9.
with the true cut hi-fi cas9 protein we
were able to preserve 84 percent in
indel
and 88
of homology directed repairs are hdr
when compared to wild type cast 9.
so again really demonstrating that with
our truecut hificast9 protein
from an on target editing efficiency
perspective it performed nearly as well
as the wildtype cast 9 again being able
to preserve over 80
or on target editing in primary t cells
so on the slide you'll find the truecard
hifi casino protein performance in human
ipscs so for this particular experiment
we picked three different gene to target
hbb1 hbb2 and heck four
and the reason why we pick heck four is
because it's a well-studied site for
off-target effects in different cells
on the left hand side shown here is the
dot plot graph which similar to what we
saw in primary t cells the true cut
hi-fi cas9
registered significantly less of target
events which is represented by the gray
dots as compared to the other two cas9
enzymes that we benchmark against
and then on the right hand side with the
bar graph this time we're
showing the data specifically for heck
four
so in looking at the truecut test9
protein v2 or our wow type we saw nine
off-target events registered
and then in looking at the other
supplier hi-fi cast nine we saw six off
target events and finally when using the
true cut hificast nine we registered
four off target events
so that reduction that we saw from nine
to four
when compared to the y-type cas9 protein
represents about 55 elimination of
off-target events when compared to wild
type cast nine
right so this further confirm and
demonstrate again that by using the true
cut hi-fi cast 9 we were able to achieve
that higher specificity in human ipscs
compared to
both the wildtype cast 9
and the other supplier hificast 9.
so in summary what we learned from
today's presentation is that off target
effects or cleavage is a problem for
many crispr cast 9 application
off-target events can lead to unintended
edits
which could introduce a variable or an
unknown into your genome editing
experiments
we learned that there are several
strategies that can be implemented to
help minimize off-target effects these
include the use of rnp delivery format
the use of optimized or high scoring
guide rna
and finally the use of a high fidelity
cas9 nucleus
and then we saw today
that we were able to identify the
optimal high fidelity cast 9 which
ultimately became the in vitrogen true
cut hificast 9 protein which have
demonstrated superior performance in
reducing off-target events while so
maintaining high on-target editing
efficiency in both primary t-cells and
human ipscs
so with that i would like to thank you
for your time
and we'll open to
questions
that was great thank you so much pandita
um we had a lot of questions come in so
we're going to go ahead and get to the
question and answer session right away
if there still is a question you'd like
to ask you can still do so now um just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
okay pandita let's go ahead and get
started so the first question
is if my guide rna has predicted off
targets
how do i figure out if i actually have
cleavage at those sites
yeah thanks louise that's a really good
question um so for a lot of the
experiments right like this sort of
verification as far as checking if the
off targets actually occurred isn't
really necessary um typically you know
that that sort of verification is done
when we're when you're at that um high
value so clonal cell line step um so
essentially the the thought here is that
you know by using a high fidelity cast 9
to
reduce that off target effects you would
have that peace of mind knowing that
it's already going to be reduced so it's
not necessary that you would have to
conduct
a tech seek analysis always just to
check that the off target effect happens
um so you know that's that's sort of the
approach that we would recommend so it's
really more peace of mind until you get
to potentially a really high value
clonal cell line or something where you
need to verify yeah okay that makes
sense um similar obviously question
about off targets um there were a lot of
off targets in the experiments you
showed with the wild type cas9
were those guide rnas predicted to be so
non-specific
yeah again another great question
good for catching that right
so
a lot of the cases in the data that we
we showed we intentionally actually
chose what we call a malicious or bad
guide rna um just because you know just
to see that we know that at this target
there's going to be a lot of off target
so it's just more measurable and sort of
meaningful to see that to be able to see
the reduction in off-target effects when
using the hi-fi um
and again right you know
that's sort of what it is so yeah that's
that's exactly what we did we
intentionally picked the bad guide our
enable to demonstrate the ability to
reduce
that makes sense yeah otherwise there's
not much to measure right right
otherwise you're seeing like one dot or
something you know so that's right
um so this question came in when you
were showing the um the screenshots of
the true design software um and so the
question has to do with the score that's
shown
for the guide rnas um and it asks what
does your score represent is that the
predicted cutting efficiency
yeah so again great question so for the
score that we um in the screenshot that
we showed there's a column that says
score so um that's actually a com so
that
that scoring is not representative of
the efficiency percentage but what it
does is it actually accounts for three
different parameters actually so the
first one being you know efficiency is
one of the parameters or factors that we
take to account the number of predicted
off target and also the distant um from
from to the the target site so it's a
combination or it takes into account
three different factors and then it kind
of generates that gives you a score um
and louise if
you know do you have any uh additional
information no i think i think you
explained that just right i mean it um
it's exactly that right so the higher
the score
the higher the predicted success right
not not necessarily literally
you know if you see a score of 90 we're
not saying that we'll get 90 percent
cutting right but we're saying it's
probably better than one that scores you
know 60 or 70 percent right exactly
um here's a nice straightforward one do
you sell the hi-fi cast 9 as a plasmid
good question so no we don't sell hi-fi
as a plasmid we sell it as you know rnp
right um or protein
so that's a that's a good
straightforward question
yep and you made the point um about the
plasmid format being less desirable from
a specificity standpoint in general
right so you're not continuing to
potentially
you know leave a nucleus in your cells
longer than it needs to be to write make
it cut yeah yeah yep that's right
um okay so next question back to the
true design um what is the difference
between
the guide rna from the true design
software and the ones available on your
website
yeah um so i'm actually going to pass
this one to you louise sure yeah kind of
helps to have a second product manager
on the line yeah
um so
the the the guide rnas that you find on
our website um
not in the software those are
pre-designed
with an algorithm
to predict highly functional knock out
so if you're just trying to knock out
your gene
um these guides go through um again it's
an algorithm for both efficiency as well
as having
um a very rigorous specificity check
so for for on the web you can just
search for your gene um we have
pre-designs for human or mouse and then
you can just click to order whereas the
true design software
is really more focused as a tool
for precise gene editing if you're doing
hdr if you're doing knock-in
and if you need to make a cut in a very
specific region
that's really what it's designed for and
it also supports
additional species beyond human and
mouse so if you're doing something
really customized we we would direct you
to to the true design software tool
um thanks
appreciate the chance to answer that um
yeah so back to your data um and this is
this is kind of related to the um the
specificity question about the guides
that we used what percent decrease in
off targets should i expect to see
so with the true cut hificast nine we
tested it as i mentioned um in the
presentation and several cell types um
you know primary t cells ipscs so
overall
in general we are expecting at least 80
reduction again that's going to depend
on you know the different cell types and
sort of the the intended target as well
but from
from the data that we generated the
benchmarking data we do
expect to see over 80 reduction in off
targets compared to the wild type test9
version
and i would think it's also really going
to depend kind of based on the data you
showed
if you have a pretty non-specific guide
with like 60 off targets
you might be able to reduce that you
know to five yeah but if you have a
guide that only has five to begin with
you know maybe you only drop to one or
two but so the percentage is is kind of
going to be indicative right of the
starting point because your earlier
point about how good is the guide right
right yeah that's a good point
yeah
um
oh this is a good one will will the true
design software suggest
when the hi-fi cast 9 is necessary
yes great question again and as i
mentioned you know with the true design
software and it being almost like a
one-stop shop where you can um order all
your other genome editing reagents as
well but both versions of the cas9
protein will be available for purchase
through the software um it would just be
you know kind of up to the customer to
the user right to determine which one
would be most appropriate for your for
your experiment um as as we've talked
about um for situations where there are
a lot of good high scoring or high
scoring guide rnas maybe in those
situations and you could you know um opt
for the wild type but of course in
situations where there are not a lot of
high scoring guide rna available you can
um order the hificast nine through that
software
right yeah we really we really leave it
up to the to the user yeah
um
so this is actually interesting delivery
question um do i need to re-optimize
my rnp delivery conditions if i switch
to the hifi cas9
and i assume the question is around if i
switch from the wild type to the hi-fi
cast that's right yeah i assume that
exactly yeah yeah yeah no so the it's
the same delivery conditions for both
protein which is obviously kind of
convenient right because so whether
you're using electroporation or
lipofectamine um you don't have to
change the conditions um you know
by switching from wild type to the hifi
it's they both use the same delivery
conditions
right that's nice
and actually it looks like our last
question
um is is kind of similar or maybe it
even came from the same person
um
does it matter if some of my experiments
are with regular cast nine and others
are with hifi cast nine or can i switch
between them
yeah right great question so yes you
could switch between the two
um you know again because both are
protein format um
you know it's it's gonna depend on like
i like i mentioned right like what are
you uh what are you looking to achieve
but but of course you can switch between
the wild type and the hi-fi no worries
both are the same
in the same protein format so um which
is really nice right like you can kind
of depending on what you're looking to
address if you have a off target um a
concern around off targets then you can
just conveniently change uh switch to
our hificat9 protein with no right um no
impact yeah
excellent well that was the last
question that was submitted um unless
there's more that i just am not looking
at right now those are the ones that i
captured during your talk
um but so before we go i just want to
thank you one more time um if there are
any questions that we didn't have time
to answer live
um we will address those by email i'm
using the address that was provided when
you registered
so thank you again to the audience for
joining us today we also want to thank
labroot and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this will be available for viewing on
demand so you'll get
a lab routes email alert when it's
available for replay and we of course
would encourage you to share that email
with that link information with any of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
so with that i thank everyone again for
joining us and hope you have a great day